what game  Scott Brooks his team's still in the  playoff hunt beast  Amy to play three games back in the loss  column out of the 8th seed  [Applause]  close  four to shoot  and Rose is money  MVPD rose full bloom for Derrick Rose  tonight 29 points and then the  Timberwolves get the basketball take it  away  Santa Ram ski with no choice but to  reach in and Powell Teague  [Applause]  [Music]  they're pros to sizing up Jeff Green  gives him to step back  Derek green when you thoughtfully look  people who look at Derrick Rose's game  winners and we've done this before if  you look at the game winners that he's  hit most of them have come from that  spot on the floor right side of the  floor either the attacker but those  jumpers that he's hitting the bag just  go back on look at Derrick Rose game  winners in Chicago oh my goodness jeff  Teague just takes the basketball away  [Applause]